[Musique]
nouvelle édition du 7 8 les invités
merci de nous rejoindre une nouvelle
fois aujourd'hui 8 septembre 2016 nous
reviendrons sur l'ouverture de la
première édition du paris cela jeune
championne chips est une compétition
inédite ce point d'affrontement entre
ceux qui ont écrit l histoire du golfe
et c'est à saint quentin en yvelines que
se déroule au golf national
rencontre avec l'organisateur dans
quelques minutes elle met tout de suite
nous vous parlons éducation plus
particulièrement du numérique à l'école
la ville d'elancourt en lançant cette
rentrée son projet à bouge ta classe à
un projet en partenariat avec la
délégation au numérique éducatif de
l'académie de versailles et la
circonscription d'elancourt concrètement
ce sont six écoles élémentaires qui sont
concernés pourront présenter ce
dispositif et son ambition je reçois ce
soir jean michel fourgous le maire de la
commune ce n'est pas son coup d'essai
dans ce domaine en 2012 déjà il avait
remis un rapport au gouvernement un
rapport sur le thème apprendre autrement
à l'ère du numérique bonsoir jean michel
fourgous soit en quoi consiste
concrètement ce nouveau projet bouge ta
classe qui concerne donc six écoles de
votre commune écoutez elancourt savent
ils disent
on embauche un ancien géant de recherche
question est un doctorat de psychologie
et je m'ennuie à l'école et non j'ai
toujours voulu faire bouger cette
pédagogie on a commencé avec la mémoire
à des moments théâtraux de mécanismes
avec le numérique pour développer la
mémoire ensuite ça a été la lecture
ensuite c'était la façon d'échanger
entre elles elles ensuite ça a été le
prof qui soit beaucoup plus participatif
avec les élèves qu'ils soient moins
magistral moins frontale dans sa
pédagogie bon ensuite ça a été la partie
mixtes c'est-à-dire une partie de dons
comme on dit en présence et avec le prof
une partie allait à la maison maintenant
voilà un élève il apprend dans la classe
dans plusieurs types d'ateliers déjà il
apprend dans le bus aussi quelquefois et
il apprend la maison donc cesser ses
mixes mobiles ont donc aujourd'hui on
voit bien et puis il apprend par le teny
donc l'animation dès qu'on ne sait plus
du tout la même chose qu'avec le livre
où les photocopies violette lèvres
souvenez qu'on avait bon donc c'est
vraiment un autre univers et donc et
l'encours est vraiment un laboratoire
d'ingénierie pédagogique dont
d'innovation pédagogique est en fait dû
manquer une étape alors essayez les
robots ou si vous savez donc les enfants
ils s'assoient les enfants pour pour
programmer le robot avec leur tablette
ils écrivent plus comme un peu moins ils
s'écrivent toujours misé écrivain peu
moins avec la table est bon donc on sait
et a interrogé sur l'environnement ce
ratio temporel aujourd'hui l'espace doit
suivre l'espace
l'ensemble est intéressé adapté
au fait que vous avez tantôt des robots
vous avez tantôt d'état blaise est en
taule teny autant que vous avez
l'exercice écrit donc on peut pas élever
un enfant plus haut n'est pas forcément
programmé pour rester huit heures naci
le fait sur une chaise sans bouger la
face à une table pour la la ça allait
plus justifié cette hâte donc on teste à
nouvel environnement spatio temporelle
où effectivement l'enfant peut changer
de posture il peut s'asseoir par terre
pour qu'on voit mais son robot il peut
être couché même sur un fauteuil qui
s'allonge y regarder sa tablette comme
ça il peut être assis peut être debout
là donc on a d'autres postures
ses errances musique de soule est c'est
l'enseignant qui pilote toujours quand
même c'est l'intérieur ont trouvé ce que
l'exercice toi donc tu tenais pluton ce
gros pardon donc et avec logo vous
changer d'outil souvent vous changez de
contenu et vous changent également de
postures démagogiques donc ça ça
renouvelle aux stimuli segmente la
motivation les lèvres seulement le
plaisir d'apprendre ça elle montre la
créativité parce que ils échangent
différemment les enfants aient cessé
dans les échanges qu'on apprend donc où
on s'aperçoit que cet espace temporel
aussi il est nécessaire de le faire
évoluer de tester de nouvelles de
nouveaux environnements c'est ce qu'on
fait avec bouge tes places donc qui
effectue à cette place cette fois ci les
causes seco élémentaire donc il tombe en
3d c'est une bulle hier donc et c'est
ici que vous avez mais un plat c'est
justement ces différents outils on peut
peut-être s'y attendait un petit peu il
ya cette pédagogie individualisée
1400 tablettes nous et qu'ils sont
maudits cédant dans les classes des
espaces dédiés pour apprendre à coder
les robots vous l'avais dit dès la
maternelle une science collaborative
drass haute tenue des visioconférences
en anglais aussi en petits groupes est
ce que tout ça a pas besoin d'être assis
pour la visioconférence ou ai parlé à
l'écran et surtout ça vous avez vous le
disais ça fait une dizaine d'années que
ça a été lancée sur votre commune vous
avez évalué un peu les méthodes qu'ils
avaient été appliqués les résultats
qu'elle a été obtenue est ce que c'est
encore comptes aux dix ans pour faire un
premier lion ces résultats très
difficile c'est très cher de dévaluer
donc chaud des élèves il faut plusieurs
années qu'il faut pas thibout
ne fait ni par le fonds en banque était
la vie tous les sinon il faut il faut
ouvrir su faire confiance à des gens qui
ont trait sur de très gros échantillons
c'est le cas des américains par exemple
travaillent sur des milliers bien sûr de
dd d'élèves et là vous avez des taux de
progression de près de 30% je pense à
une étude qui s'appelle marzano qui
montrent qu'il ya une évolution de ip
man show près de 30% des résultats
scolaires à condition que vous y êtes
tout l'environnement du mexique les
profs soient bien impliquée je veux bien
formés c'est aussi le l'élément qu'on a
appris en cours l'importance du prof qui
qui a un rôle encore plus important
qu'avoir envie de vous allez on passe le
court pas du tout le prof en fait à une
valeur ajoutée pédagogique supérieur
avant et en plus il a plus de plaisir le
prof enseigne et donc plus de plaisir à
apprendre pour l'élève et plus de
plaisir en a enseigné pour le pro bowl
yeux je pense que il ya on est quand
même
et d'ailleurs c'est que les gens les
gens cherchent des dérogations qu'il
faut pour bien aller dans les écoles ils
encourent 10 rebonds facile à gérer rien
et qu'il vienne même habitée est en
cours qui achètent des maisons et encore
pour sept procès oui pis dernier point
on peut même aussi traiter également
mené par l'autisme
l'éducation nationale a choisi elancourt
chaud plus de 60 villes dans les
logiciels en cours pour créer une classe
avec nous une classe pour les enfants
autistes parce que c'est un vrai
problème c'est très difficile et donc
effectivement avec l environnement de ce
type là dont on vient de parler vous
pouvez effectivement bien sûr gérer une
classe d'autistes du département avec
des sûr beaucoup plus avec des
coefficients de potentiel de réussite
nettement super parce que vous avez ce
ces outils et ce nouvel environnement je
vais vous donner un nom tout de même
d'une personne qui ne viendra pas
s'installer à elancourt ça c'est certain
c'est philippe guillaume gouix c'est un
ingénieur centralien hauteur avec une
enseignante d'un essai sur le numérique
à l'école je vous vois déjà sur rire
parce que je sais que le sujet va vous
fâcher les pour lui de l'école numérique
est un désastre pédagogique est
salutaire alors je vais rencontrer sur
un plateau hier monsieur bihouix ne pas
confondre avec monsieur bouygues
bouygues était un bâtisseur un
constructeur
chinois x est plutôt un démolisseur
certains c'est un économe et le mauvais
et colonial bon écolo qui soulève des
vrais problèmes et c'est bien puis il ya
celui qui est là qui utilise le principe
de précaution frais plus rien fait et
ses enfants mon rêve s'est passé a lieu
ici des choses qui sont fausses ils
disent idées des expériences qui se sont
inexacts par exemple ici bizarre c'est
l'expérience pizarro monnaie en or n'est
25e à foix aussi quand même on est 25e à
pisé 35e à savoir sa peine bougé depuis
les faire bouger ses méthodes et lg qui
inquiète la france entière par semaine
en cours et lui avait remis le site we
hope is he a dit que le numérique au
collège je les enfants de 15 ans ça
marchait pas alors on regarde l'étude
pied je la connais très bien qu'on est
en fait une bise elle parle d'une
enquête qui a lu avant 2012 alors avant
2012 dans les collèges il n'y avait pas
de tablette donc c'est quand même elle
ne savait même pas ils avaient sorti ça
comme salon zee interpréter il a fait un
bouquin il le dit lui-même il m'a dit le
no le mot le titre un peu fort mais
c'est mon éditeur qui m'a dit de mettre
ça pour vous il n'y a pas de départ au
delà de ceux de celui évoqué n'est pas
sérieux vraiment au delà de ça sur le
numérique a pas de débat à avoir
aujourd'hui c'est forcément une plus
value il ya une seule lui ceci est
indiscutablement une plus value d'abord
vous lutter contre les inégalités
d'ailleurs ça c'est le seul point de
jouer plus d'accord parce qu'il avait
pris un élément dans l'épisode 10 ans
oui les inégalités augmentent en france
et jaén inégalités sont fortes en france
et le numérique est la meilleure réponse
parce que les enfants quel que soit leur
origine ils ont accès aux eaux à la même
connaissance moi je me souviens quand je
visitais des appartements un peu plus
modeste que d'autres il y avait il n'y
avait pas de livres le dictionnaire été
déchirés et tachés avec des taches de
rex a que là vous avez des enfants ils
ont le même contenu un accès même
contenu aux mêmes conditions pour
apprendre et bien je peux vous dire
voilà et et ça c'est le numérique ça
répond quand même à tous ses appels ses
montres le rappel l'autonomie d'un
enfant et ça augmente sa concentration
sa créativité
et saluts et saluts et saluts prépara à
demain à trouver un job parce que demain
si un enfant n'a pas une culture
numérique dans le monde de demain je
vais vous dire il ne trouvera pas un
travail donc voilà il nous reste
quelques minutes voudrais vous faire
réagir tout de même aussi concernant
l'éducation sur cette grève qui avait
lieu aujourd'hui 8 septembre cette grève
contre la réforme des collèges plutôt
assez peu suivie au niveau national
moins de 5% des professeurs des collèges
publics qui étaient en grève sur la
réforme du collège est ce qu'il va
falloir la revoir cette réforme du
collège il ya déjà certains candidats
que ce soit plutôt à droite et l'église
de toute façon si nous revenons aux
affaires on reviendra dessus tout en
pensez quoi égouttez
25e à bizarre je voulais 10 35e au
classement de shanghai pour les
universités on a un but est de 65
milliards pour l'éducation il ya
d'autres pays qui sont plus performants
que nous qu'ils dépensent moins d'argent
donc il faut être très fort mais c'est
tout l'esat réformer les manoirs nous
parle de réforme des collèges guinée qui
est amorcé non je peux je pense que le
problème le premier problème de
l'éducation nationale c'est qu'il faut
qu'il n'est il faut pas que
les gens soient idéologisé jeu quelqu'un
qui arrive avec des grandes idées but
mais vous avez misé en place canon à bon
mais vous avez des preuves que ça non
non non mais comprenez
intellectuellement ça cette fois arrêté
ça on ne la qualité des rythmes
scolaires le coup c'est près de 2
milliards enfin ça désorganisée dans 80%
des cas ça marche pas que ça marche mal
ça désorganise et les équipes
pédagogiques que leaders de demain ce
sera rue je crois poser dû l'entendre
bon on inventera autre chose peut-être
plus de 2 de vérifier le devoir des
enfants qui est qui et les huiles et des
doigts de 2 en fin de journée mais mais
mais pas à pas des choses comme ça on
mélange tout on va à l'école pour
apprendre pour pour un
projet solide en question est un projet
qui vient du du réel du terrain du
concret les idoles m on arrête genre la
france va demander si on continue à
changer leur direction mais bientôt il y
aura des élections malgré tout avant
tout ça il ya une primaire qui qui se
dessine pour la droite avec un dépôt de
candidature pour les primaires à droite
fixer la limite est fixée à demain
est-ce que vous avez accordé votre
parrainage dans des gîtes et moi je sors
d'un 20 propositions
avec 150 parlementaires de génération
entreprise que vous avez remis à nicolas
sarkozy je suis je suis le porte parole
ce groupe de parlementaires je les ai
remis pas seulement un budget remis à
nicolas sarkozy ce dernier aide à tous
les candidats
l'essentiel des plus gros candidats
coeur ont repris l'essentiel de ses
propositions les vous donc c'est digne
donc moi je ne peux pas je supporte
parole mais en plus dans ce groupe de
150 plantes il faut savoir qu elle a
quatre qui sont candidats donc je ne
peux pas moi animé
préparer ce sont tous mes amis moi je me
bats effectivement contre le socialisme
idéologique d'extrême gauche qu'on en
france pas contre le social libéralisme
mouloud pas le socialisme européen le
chiot libéralisme européen belles
allemandes n'ont jamais - la croix vous
pourriez voter c'est un grand débat
c'est un grand débat c'est un débat chez
à fait à jour je vous répondrais une les
voilà donc moi je me bats contre c'est
de ce socialisme archaïque qui n'a pas
rompu et donc ne savons pas qui vous
avez rêvé pour aller et je me bats
contre ça que je ne me bats pas contre
mes amis à partir de mouiller auprès de
mes idées avec le travail que j'ai fait
que ce groupe nommé difficile d'aller
arbitré deux saisons savait c'est lent
c'est dans deux mois c'est après le tout
c'est lui qui a été désigné
démocratiquement mais voilà je vais pas
l'aimer
opposés mes amis dans le jeune
génération résident déjà papables sur
les hommes moi je me base sur les ide on
accepter les sensibilités voilà ça va
très bien merci jean michel fourgous est
revenu sur ce plateau du 7-8 elle les
invite l émission qui se poursuit à
présent avec du sport le golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines qui
accueille depuis aujourd'hui la première
édition du paris les jeunes championship
plus de 50 de champion et anciens
vainqueurs de tournois majeurs sont
présents pour ce rendez-vous
l'organisateur était est au micro de
nickel et vidéo parue en train de
devenir une capitale du golfe on a
chaque année les pelles de france
la ryder cup qui va être un événement
énorme
pari al'avantage de barbie public
d'avoir les passionnés de golf et
d'avoir un les fumées parcours des
français probablement les plus beaux
parcours du monde est-ce que vous pouvez
nous présenter la compétition c'est une
première édition c'est une première
émission pour la france il s'agit du
tour européen seniors c'est à dire les
joueurs qui ont plus de 50 ans les
légendes qui ont dès les 30 ans l'ont
remis à notre sport le genre avec lequel
m
qu'on a vu sur les parcours depuis des
années c'est une invitation officielle
saba
pendant trois jours vendredi samedi
dimanche que quel sportif est retrouvé
sur ce parcours là on a eu beaucoup de
chance cette année on a un plateau
énorme
vraiment l'aimer
des états unis
on a les français jan vanhevel on a un
plateau absolument magnifique première
année je suis vraiment très heureux que
les joueurs aient cassé les objectifs
pour cette première année attirer du
monde avant celle l on avait deux
éléments qu'on maîtrisait pas c'était le
climat et le document lagache ans il va
faire beau les buts on a fait l'entrée
gratuite l'essayer le thé limiter le
plus possible et on espère vraiment que
tous les amateurs de belles fait même
les gens qui ont découvrir ces sports
dans le tournoi tels sont les premiers
retours sur cette compétition même si
elle n'a pas eu lieu et qu'elles se
cachaient des prothèses positif sur
l'organisation de cette compétition un
pur moment là beaucoup de chance on a la
chance d'avoir la presse qui a suivi tel
bel et bien là la chance d'avoir les
joueurs c'est le plus important le
joueur s'est vu
on a beaucoup de presse on a beaucoup de
civils
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
soutiennent les sponsors nous aident
pour maman ça démarre bien on espérait
que sa valeur
pendant les trois jours et surtout pas
non plus important c'est le comique et
l'objectif c'est de faire perdurer cette
compétition bien sûr on a un contrat sur
trois ans avec la fédération française
de golf est avec lui répondent tour
évidemment l'objectif c'est de continuer
de poursuivre d'en faire un tournoi
important sur le retour en paix
sur ces trois ans est ce qu'on voulait
encore développer du coup ce soit par
les sept jeunes ce qui aura plus de
légende du cou qui viendront s ajouter
aux des jeunes présentent cette année
c'est l'objectif cette année c'est le
premier à l'est on a fait avec les
moyens qu'on avait avec ce nouvel opus
est chaque année le faire un peu monter
les prix de faire un peu monter le
plateau est d'avoir un tournoi qui
évolue d'année en année et ce sera ici
et déflation elle a dépêché les
insolents l'année prochaine c'est sûr en
2018 probablement dans un autre belge
parisien cause de la ryder cup nous
fermons cette édition rendez vous à des
lundis à partir de 18h45 pour un nouveau
cette ut les invités est déjà présente
pour les replays sur notre site internet
[Musique]